[Musique]
on m'a demandé de vous raconter une
histoire une histoire d'humanité et de
technologie plus précisément une
histoire de nouveaux lieux pour
l'humanitaire et le développement des
nouveaux lieux où des gens comme vous et
moi pouvons aller créer apprendre
partager des lieux pleins de nouvelles
technologies des lieux où l'humanité se
mélangent avec la technologie
l'histoire commence en 2014 chez nous on
est bricoleur depuis de nombreuses
générations depuis plusieurs milliers
milliers de générations je pense
probablement comme vous et c'est donc
pas surprenant qu'un un soir d'avril en
cette photo a été prise alors que
j'étais en train d'assembler ma première
imprimante 3d
ces technologies permettent enfin je
sais pas si vous êtes familier avec ces
nouvelles technologies ses technologies
de fabrication digital permettent de
créer à peu près n'importe quoi à partir
de n'importe quelle matière c'est du
moins ce que l'on entend parler quand on
entend parler dans les médias
cette technologie comme je travaillais à
l'époque au cicr comité international de
la croix rouge j'ai commencé à
m'intéresser à voir comment est ce qu'on
pouvait l'utiliser pour l'action
humanitaire
quand on parle de d'imprimantes 3d on
parle d'une série d'outils que qu'on
nomme ou qu'on peut le libérer ou qu'on
peut catégoriser sous les technologies
de fabrication digital ou fabrication
numérique
la première machine a été créée en 1952
ces machines numériques permettent
d'effectuer le travail de manière
répétitive sans se fatiguer et avec une
extrême précision
la différence entre les machines et
principalement la l'outil qu'on met au
bout et qui va être contrôlés par
l'ordinateur
ces machines évidemment ont bénéficié
des progrès de la technologie et se sont
miniaturisés ont augmenté en puissance
de calcul et sont devenus beaucoup plus
simple à utiliser
on parle on parle de technologie
exponentielle actuellement la
technologie évolue à un rythme qui
s'accélère
de plus en plus la même chose évidemment
pour ces nouvelles machines de
fabrication digital imprimante 3d
fraiseuse découpeuse laser etc
ici on voit une machine qui a été
développé il ya un peu plus de dix ans
c'est un reprap tout monté elle coûte à
peu près 200 francs et vous pouvez la
construire vous même en prenant des
pièces du do it yourself d'à côté cette
machine a la capacité de se reproduire
on imprime les pièces orange et on
achète des différents matériaux pour en
refaire une autre en a deux et ainsi de
suite la prochaine étape
on en a quatre et ainsi de suite on en a
8 et ensuite on finit après quatre sites
de fabrication à avoir 16 machines
donc après quatre cycles de fabrication
n'est capable plutôt que de faire un
objet à la fois on sera capable d'en
faire 16 à la fois et j'aime bien cette
image pour représenter le technology
exponentielle ces technologies ces
nouvelles technologies de fabrication
qui sont devenus beaucoup plus
abordables ont des lieux ces lieux
s'appelle les fab lab c'est une
contraction en fait qui tient pour
digital fabrication laboratory au
tournant du millénaire
ces nouveaux espaces qui permettent aux
gens d'être créatif de résoudre des
problèmes de faire les prototypes et
d'autres objets ont commencé à se
développer on en compte aujourd'hui plus
de 1200 à travers le monde
c'est des espaces où évidemment il ya
des machines mais des machines à lui
destiné à l'utilisation du main on a des
communautés locales mais aussi on a une
par cette masse de fab lab
on a maintenant hocine comité globale
qui s'intéressent à parfois des projets
comme ces nouveaux lieux et évidemment
son peuple et notamment parce qu'on
appelait avant des bricoleurs des
bricoleurs y en a toujours eu de nos
jours on s'est toujours les mêmes à la
différence près que d'un jour ils ont
accès à des technologies qu'on n'avait
pas avant c'est des technologies qui
vous permettent de partager
instantanément avec le monde de voir ce
que d'autres personnes ont fait de
s'inspirer et de résoudre des problèmes
ensemble on les appelle les maker ou
c'est pas vraiment la traduction de
bricoleur
mais c'est néanmoins le terme qui s'est
récemment normalisée dans le langage et
parmi cette frange nommé coeur on voit
aussi des meilleurs évidemment qui
émergent et qui qui veut le faire de
l'impact qui veulent changer le monde
qui veulent le rendre mieux plus juste
plus propres et ainsi de suite
je pense que gentiment vous voyez où je
veux en venir
cette idée comme quoi ces nouveaux
espaces qui bénéficie maintenant à peu
près la terre entière sauf les endroits
les plus complexes et reculer comment
est-ce qu'on peut les adapter et les
rendre utiles ou comment est ce qu'on
peut en faire bénéficier le monde
humanitaire le monde du développement
alors on a identifié déjà trois cas
d'utilisation supra ordonnée
le support aux opérations humanitaires
la logistique et ainsi de suite avec la
capacité annoncée est déjà réelle de nos
jours de créer ce qu'on a besoin où on
en a besoin quand on en a besoin
évidemment ça va s'améliorer encore dans
le futur
un autre cas d'utilisation ça serait là
la de favoriser l'innovation dans le
secteur humanitaire en exposant les
humanitaires à ces nouvelles
technologies à ces nouvelles approches
et le troisième cas qui nous intéresse
ici évidemment beaucoup plus c'est
l'autonomisation des populations
affectées ou les personnes qui souffrent
soit d'un conflit soit d'un désastre
naturel ou d'autres conditions socio
économiques défavorables
on va donc voir quelles adaptations sont
nécessaires à ces lieux qui sont chez
nous relativement facile à imaginer
on a de l'électricité on a de la
connectivité on a relativement
facilement des endroits du financement
de l'éducation et d'autres choses comme
la paix par exemple maintenant vous
imaginez déployer un fab lab tels que je
décris dans un endroit où il n'y a pas
d'électricité pas que de pâtes
connectivité ou potentiellement et les
conflits et vous avez déjà d'une
circonstance qui est beaucoup plus
pénible
donc quelles vont être les adaptations
nécessaires qu'on va pouvoir mettre en
place pour néanmoins pouvoir déployer
ses nouveaux espaces et donc là on a
commencé maintenant l'année passée en
fait avec une organisation que vous
connaissez proment tous terre des hommes
on a fait une preuve du concept et on a
déployé un fab lab humanitaire dans un
concept dans un pardon dans un contexte
de réfugiés en grèce des réfugiés qui
viennent du moyen-orient les conflits
actuels ont généré un certain
déplacement
ces personnes restent d'habitude
quelques mois en grèce avant que leur
sort soit décidé à ce qu'ils
continuaient ce qui reste est ce qu'ils
repartent chez eux et ainsi de suite et
donc tiers des hommes a voulu voir
qu'elle sait quel serait l'impact en
fait de ces de ces nouveaux espaces de
ces nouvelles technologies de ces
nouvelles opportunités pour les réfugiés
on a déployé un fab lab est en fait les
premiers effets sont notables on
remarque un impact positif sur le côté
psychosocial sur l'intégration des
individus le fab lab et pas seulement
ouvert aux réfugiés mais aussi à la
population locale il ya de l'éducation
informelle qui est qui entreprises avec
des activités régulières on motive les
gens à apprendre et ainsi de suite
mais évidemment même si cette première
expérience a pour l'instant relativement
bien marché et qu'on a récolté des
données qu'on sait combien de gens le
fréquentent l'endroit
ça ne nous dit pas forcément quel est
l'impact réel sur les individus donc ça
serait un premier défi évidemment majeur
qu'on doit surmonter pour montrer que
notre démarche a de la valeur pour
montrer cet impact
il suffit pas de collecter des données
stage démographique quotidienne et les
afficher à l'écran il faut pouvoir faire
une étude un peu plus longitudinale sur
l'impact de ces lieux de ces nouvelles
pratiques de cette exposition sociale
sur les sur les bénéficiaires ou les
utilisateurs un deuxième défi évidemment
vous l'imaginez c'est l'infrastructure
voilà un endroit typique ou
potentiellement au burkina faso on va
vouloir déployer un de ces fablab
humanitaire ou là plutôt dans un
contexte de développement
c'est des endroits où les endroits
humanitaire les contextes humanitaire ou
les contrats de développement sont des
envois endroits qui sont presque par
définition complexe 10 temps difficiles
d'accès et parfois en crise
évidemment là les premiers problèmes
qu'on va rencontrer ça va être
l'électricité la connectivité par
exemple comment est ce qu'on va faire
cette marche et ses machines
un deuxième un deuxième défi qui
évidemment est un peu tous liés on parle
de la même situation
ça va être la logistique comment est-ce
qu'on va acheminer les choses qu'est ce
qu'on va trouver à disposition sur place
et comment est-ce qu'on va éviter de
devoir faire d un port systématique de
pièces de rechange de matériel
divers et variés alors qu'on pourrait si
possible essayez d'utiliser les
ressources qui sont à disposition dans
l'est dans les environnements dans les
environnements dans les environs et
évidemment ça c'est aussi un gros
problème à résoudre un autre des fils
l'absence de scolarisation ou la
déscolarisation précoce ont beaucoup de
jeunes ne vont pas à l'école
ceux qui rentrent en primaire ou au
secondaire risque de sortir pour des
raisons multiples et variées et comment
est ce qu'on va pouvoir travailler sur
une base qui est pas forcément toujours
très stable avec des jeunes qui n'ont
pas forcément les connaissances que nos
enfants ici ou dans les pays développés
pourrait privilégier pourrait avoir
alors il n'y a pas que des défis et puis
je les cite pas tous j'ai essayé de me
concentrer un petit peu sur les
principaux il ya eu aussi les éléments
de réponse évidemment si on n'a pas de
d'électricité on va faire comme les gens
sur place on va la produire à l'heureux
et le produisent d'habitude avec des
générateur à essence ou diesel
mais dans les cas les plus les plus
avancés entre guillemets on va trouver
l'utilisation par exemple ici le panneau
solaire qui actionne un ventilateur dans
ce cas là et qui pompent de l'air frais
à 70 mètres de profondeur où la personne
qui est en train de creuser dans ce dans
ce puits a besoin d'air frais évidemment
pour faire son travail et pour survivre
donc on va essayer de développer cette
approche sur les énergies renouvelables
un autre élément de réponse ça va être
de faire la plus déjà d'acheter ce qu'on
peut sur place ou dans les environs
et si possible de faire ce qu'on peut
dans un fab lab proches ou dans la
région
là on voit une machine
une imprimante 3d qui a été construite à
gaza ils en ont six autres ils ont une
petite usine en fait où ils prêts ils
produisent des pièces médicales utile
parce que pas disponible à gaz et par
exemple juste pour vous donner une idée
de ce qui a été produit sur cette
imprimante 3d qui a promis a coûté de
nouveau moins de 200 francs
ben voilà un stéthoscope qui tout
récemment a été pillée reviewed revue
par des pairs et qui marche aussi bien
parce tête au scope à 300 francs alors
que celui là coûte seulement 3 3 francs
3 centimes donc vous voyez
potentiellement l'intérêt que ces
nouvelles technologies peuvent avoir
spécifiquement comme dans les contextes
à gaza un autre élément de réponse
évidemment c'est la revalidation d'aidé
revalorisation des déchets quand je vous
dis qu'on a des problèmes
d'infrastructures de logistique
évidemment amener de la matière première
qui pourrait être utilisé dans ces fab
lab comme on le ferait ici aux
etats-unis en europe
ailleurs dans notre pays
là bas ça va pas être possible on va pas
pour aller acheter le multiplient en
peuplier ou je sais pas quoi
et pis là mais pour le découper à la
fraiseuse ou à la découpe et de lasers
ou avoir dû finalement à profusion pour
imprimer des objets en 3d par contre ce
qu'il y a c'est assez c'est assez
impressionnant c'est il ya une il ya une
source inépuisable de matériaux qu'on
pourrait revaloriser transformer les
bouteilles en plastique en filaments
pour l'impression 3d et et d'autres
approches qui pourraient être utilisés
de cette manière je cite là par exemple
des initiatives comme precious plastique
qui développe exactement c'est ces
technologies et fêtes approchent un
autre élément de réponse aussi con que
l'on peut amener ici c'est dans le cas
spécifique de gaza dans le cade camp de
réfugiés où les gens en fait sont comme
à gaza ils peuvent pas vraiment la
plupart du temps du moins quitter ces
camps de réfugiés mais néanmoins veulent
avoir une activité
participez à la collectivité c'est
l'inclusion dans l'économie digitale
l'économie digitale c'est toute cette
économie virtuelle elle vaut des
milliards actuellement et c'est en
constante augmentation
on peut acheter des choses sur le web on
n'a plus besoin d'aller au magasin
moi je peux design et des objets des
oeuvres d'art ou des solutions utiles je
peux les vendre et vous pouvez les
acheter sur le web aussi ça devient
complètement dit virtualisés ici on voit
mahmoud à gaza en fait qui travaille
depuis without borders une angie au
local qui permet aux gens aux
professionnels digitaux de gaza gaza
plusieurs universités mais seulement un
million d'habitants
donc il ya plein de savoir-faire digital
et numériques sur place mais par contre
il n'arrive pas à travailler notamment
pour le marché local pour travailler
néanmoins il travaille depuis gaza pour
des marchés arabes et autres et vendre
leurs compétences à l'étranger
on pourrait très bien s'imaginer
approche similaire pour des réfugiés ou
d'autres endroits où les gens on aurait
de la difficulté à voir une de
l'employabilité avec les activités
locales
un autre élément de réponse encore c'est
former les formateurs et là on est
vraiment dans un souci de pérennité
comment est-ce qu'on peut assurer la
pérennité d'un endroit comme sa
pérennité parce que potentiellement les
budgets du programme humanitaire ou du
développement vont couper le fab lab
n'aura plus de budget mais néanmoins il
intéresse la communauté donc une
approche évidente c'est de travailler
sur la formation des formateurs faire en
sorte que les cursus d'enseignement qui
soit promulguée dans le fab lab
permettent gentiment à la base
d'utilisateurs à venir et à renflouer
et animer le lieu lui-même encore a cité
un atout majeur la curiosité humaine
partout j'ai été j'ai visité plusieurs
pays là ces dernières années est en fait
les humains sont très curieux y voient
de la technologie se demande comment est
ce qui peut l'utiliser comment est ce
qu'ils peuvent en bénéficier et ils
apprennent très rapidement en fait les
plus jeunes encore plus rapidement avec
les 16 secondes qu'il me reste je
voulais encore vous parler de la suite
on a donc un premier fable habran grèce
il y en a d'autres qui sont planifiées
en ukraine en roumanie à gaza comme j'en
parlais à djibouti au burkina faso et au
kenya
le but la maintenance et de développer
vraiment 7,7 ce consortium qui va nous
permettre de d'avancé d'avoir d'autres
partenariats
d'autres organisations humanitaires
d'intéresser des sponsors privés ou des
fondations et ainsi de suite pour
développer le modèle pour apprendre des
différences preuve de concept qu'on a
mis en place et pour finalement
formaliser une approche qui va permettre
aux humanitaires et aux secteurs du
développement de déployer des fab lab
ces nouveaux espaces numériques dans
leur contexte
voilà je vous remercie pour votre
attention et à la prochaine
[Musique]